all right uh so today's draft and you
know it sounded like a good idea when i
suggested it and then i actually had to
do the research and the thought and it's
this isn't as easy as i thought the best
nfl wingman in honor of the top gun top
gun 35th birthday i have a trivia
question for you chris at the beginning
of top gun
did this oh well i don't know maybe he
won't be able to get this at the
beginning of top gun maverick sings
karaoke
to win over charlie name the song and
the artist
you lost that love and feeling
whoa
that butt okay okay name the song who's
the artist
um
honestly i don't know i don't know
i know i don't either you don't either
you don't is it
righteous brothers i knew it was
brothers if i would have talked it
through a little bit i would have come
up with it come on old timer how did you
not know that jeez i but i didn't even
get a credit i didn't get a credit for
knowing the song i don't get anything i
mean since
everybody knows the song
i'll let you have the first pick because
i'm going to be curious to see which way
you go because you clearly came to this
dance without your dancing shoes well no
our research was done last night no
preparation hey you know what screw you
i'm going to dominate you in this draft
all right all right
and i did i had some old timers on here
so i had to think of some new world all
right first off like the ultimate
wingman like thing nfl i mean is is
gronk to brady that's number one to me i
don't even want to use quarterbacks in
this a whole lot but like grunk is like
wink like wherever tom goes me go
wherever tom throws football me catch it
tom needs security to walk into a bar
i'm his security i mean that's he's the
ultimate wingman tom doesn't want to
drink the shot i drink it for him oh
that's awesome oh i'm gronk i mean he's
the ultimate wingman i mean he says
anything i mean right he's the guy you'd
love to have at the bar you say
something stupid or not even funny and
he laughs and everybody thinks it's
funny hey i'm cool look at that he's the
ultimate wingman and grunk
similar vibe right idea yeah i i go i go
to a different city i go different
quarterback and a different tight end
travis kelsey to patrick mahomes but
it's the exact same thing right right
texas tech's in the final four who's
there next to him yeah right but the guy
who went to texas tech is travis kelsey
next to patrick mahomes in minnesota
they they win the super bowl they're
hanging out with post malone they're
they're playing uh beer pong with post
malone yeah he's he's got he's he's
protecting the meal ticket everywhere he
goes and on the field he's the ultimate
wing man too you know tr tyree kill's
covered travis kelsey's going to be open
he's always going to be there to bail
out patrick mahomes so i i think that
those are the obvious ones it gets a
little harder after it definitely does
all right next one i'm gonna go to a
receiver here i'm gonna go to like
you know your ultimate wingman you got
like the big guy and the small guy you
know that's it's david and goliath but
the ultimate wingman as far as football
is concerned dk metcalf and tyler
lockett that's what i'm gonna throw out
there it's just it's like hey you big
guy you go
you go deep and do all the big guy stuff
and i'm the real small fast guy and i'll
catch all these routes and do all that
we're an awesome wingman together i mean
i don't know that's how i envision those
voices going in my brain is stupid yeah
why is tyler locking have a high pitch
because he was a small fast guy right
and usually i just feel like they talk
like that
but yes there's no no logic to that but
i think you could argue it's as good as
a one-two tandem in all of football
definitely and they couldn't be more
opposite as far as the way they look uh
so they're a great wingman for each
other out in the football field
i i'm gonna go similar path again
although this is a new relationship it's
the young guy who's taken over the
position in minnesota adam thielen who
had been the wingman to stefan diggs is
now the wingman to justin jefferson yeah
and and uh you know a very potent
one-two punch and uh you know uh
phelan's the one who would i guess punch
out and hit his head on the
on the cockpit a very unrealistic
physical thing that happened to goose
but he still died do you know how do you
know how do you know that's unrealistic
i think it's unrejected
at one point oh it's not the wingman
that's not the wing man though see we're
getting it all screwed up the wingman's
the other plane right not the guy in the
back not the navigator either way goose
died right okay well yeah you know yes
he's he still was his wing man though
right i mean yeah but i know you're
right i guess technically it's not
exactly a wingman all right
i'm i'm stuck here i think though i'm
gonna go to running back i got a few
other good ones here but i'm going to go
to the to batman and robin in cleveland
i'm going to go to those two the wing
man i mean what a great wingman that is
hey here's the ball nick chubb run up
the middle for 70 yards oh you need a
break hey we'll bring in your wingman
yeah kareem hunt and he'll run up the
middle for 50 yards awesome i mean that
couldn't fit better i mean so talented
both are you know
chubb maybe a little bit better running
the ball hunt a little better catching
the ball it's just a perfect compliment
for that offense there in cleveland so
i'll go with with hunt and chub
uh you know it's funny
matt's telling me that he doesn't think
you understood the exercise but we all
have the same picks we have the same we
i i've got the same guys on my list so
we both misunderstood it the exact same
way i've got because i was going to go
uh but but wait
who's the wingman is hunt the white man
to chopper is chubby i guess
it's always going to be the second guy
right so chubb's the main guy hunt's got
to be i mean chubb's the main guy he's
the guy at the bar all the girls like
hunt's the guy that's the wingman at the
bar that you know gets like the
leftovers like that's what happens
i i have another running back tandem i'm
going to skip though i was going to say
latavius murray to alvin kamara but i'm
going to go instead uh on the defensive
side of the ball let's give some love
especially in tampa bay where they
rarely get the recognition they deserve
levante david right to devin white right
right levante the the the veteran he's
been there he's you know moving toward
the back end of his career devon white
the young guy who who is the straw that
stirs that drink david's sticking around
hey hey
when when you got a guy like devin white
you
no i don't need to go anywhere else uh
he makes my life a lot easier because
he's the one who's attracting the
attention he's the one who's making
things happen and i'm here just to to
cover his back yeah definitely yeah
i'm with you i i wrote that down too
that was definitely if i didn't take my
last one that would have been the pick
but yeah i mean come on oh you know oh
devin you're gonna blitz here i'll try
i'll cover travis kelsey great oh i can
blitz here now you'll cover travis
because he's great oh neither one of us
will blitz them we'll just be you know
impossible to stop chasing the ball
great i mean yeah they're pretty damn
good wing man combination there for sure
who else are you anybody else on your
list give me an all-timer
oh
like
you know duper and clayton right that
that like from who's the wingman i guess
i'm gonna say duper is the wingman to
clayton okay i'm gonna say for the sake
of since it was the young days
moss was the wingman to carter just
because he was the young guy not maybe
because he was the the
the better player what do you think
about that
uh and what was my oh you know john
taylor john taylor yeah to jerry rice
that's the other one for sure
so you're making moss the wingman to
carter i i i feel like for when carter's
i know you think so i don't know
i went with the young guy having to like
be you know the wingman at first in the
early part of his career but you're
right i guess it really should be the
other way around
and you want to have some of that
tension you want to have a little iceman
maverick tension and then they they
resolve things and at the end of the day
you can be my wingman anytime that's
right
moss is the guy moss was the maverick
moss was the guy who showed up and shook
everything up and carter was iceman so i
don't know who the wingman is in that
yeah that's a tough one
it starts off as moss being the
reluctant wingman and at the end of the
day carter embraces the fact that having
moss around made his life a hell of a
lot easier
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports